six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
our number let's go next to our caller
from the two two four area code who's
calling in today from two to four hello
that is you who's this I David this is
me LAN from Chicago
hey what's gonna I have a question about
when debating medicare-for-all something
at an argument that comes from the right
oftentimes is well we can't do a
medicare-for-all because we our
population is just way bigger than the
rest of the countries that have ever
done them yeah my my response go ahead
sorry very dumb argument as I'm sure you
noticed yeah and it doesn't really make
sense to me the the first thing I say is
okay sure we have the biggest population
but we're also the richest country in
the world is that the appropriate
response I just kind of get stuck there
what should I say in response to that
argument well you say we're bigger
meaning we have more people who need
care but we're bigger so we have more
people whose taxes would be used to fund
the system I mean it's just it's it's a
non-starter it's it's really important
not to get sucked into that argument
because there are all sorts of universal
coverage systems this includes
nationalized systems Medicare type
system single-payer University all these
these are all different configurations
of systems that get everybody coverage
or almost everybody coverage as is often
the reality and they exist in countries
that are of different sizes different
populations different geographical size
different economic priorities different
tax rates so it's just it's not a good
argument and you know so my response
would be number one we have the benefit
of a massive tax base which can spread
the cost of such a system across way
more people than lots of these other
countries meaning any one person or one
group of people's health needs are less
likely to impact or shock the system in
any kind of significant way and more
importantly by virtue of being such a
big country with so many people we also
have tons of brilliant minds that could
figure out the best way to implement
such a system so it's just it's
defeatism and
and extraordinarily ignorant to say we
have a big country so none of that would
work all right sweet thanks for taking
my call David yeah no problem I
appreciate the phone call yeah that's
just such such a dumb argument I wish
they would stop making it and they'd
probably keep making it because it does
work on some people